Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Damon Centinela, who's a professor of
communications, sociology and engineering
at the University of Pennsylvania, also author
of the book Change How to Make Big Things
Happen. Damon, I have to ask you, is Trump
right that at Upend they just can't stop talking
about him? Is that really what everybody is
fixated on there that he went to upend?
Speaker 2: Well, like most of the things Donald
Trump says, it has very little bearing on
the truth. There are very few conversations
about him. Most of what we talk about is how
to fix the policies that write in place.
Speaker 1: Well, I want to to really dove
into the meat of this book because I find
the topic very interesting, which is what
what works to achieve social change and what
does not work. And we sort of have a bit of
an example from the last year when it comes
to influencers and vaccination. There was
the idea relatively early that getting so-called
influencers to just show themselves being
vaccinated or say it's a good idea to get
vaccinated, that through their status alone,
this would convince lots of people to get
vaccinated. Good strategy, bad strategy based
on your research.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, the background here
is that the notion of influencers or highly
connected people as the key to social change
really dates back to the nineteen forties
and there's nearly a century of research on
this. And the way that we think about it is
that people who are really disproportionately
connected and so obviously most of us know
things on social media, like the Kim Kardashian
characters. Right. Who are massively connected.
And I think that we have this intuition that
comes from marketing that companies figured
out very early on, which is that someone who
is so massively connected could be really
effective for spreading things like new brands
of coconut water or new teeth whitening creams.
Right. And then there was this sort of generalization
and there were a series of popular books written
around two thousand that kind of said, well,
look, if viruses spread this way and information
spreads this way. It seems like everything
spread this way, right, every kind of initiative,
every kind of campaign, every political movement
or social change effort should try to make
use of influencers. And there's something
really appealing about that, which is that,
you know, it's kind of solves a very hard
problem. A very hard problem is how do you
get lots of people to change their beliefs
or their behavior. Vaccination is one where
there's obviously a lot of hesitancy, a lot
of uncertainty, you know, reasons why people
would resist it. And so if we could just find
the key people to initiate a change process,
you know, we would have a lot of very hard
problems solved very quickly. Right. The problem
with that view is that it turns out that the
logic of disease spreading, the logic of information
spreading doesn't generalize to contagious
behaviors that really are disruptive or that
go against the existing social norms that
challenge the way that we're thinking and
acting and require additional more additional
effort or additional cost. And that's really
the crux of my work, is showing that the core
intuition about influencers really only works
for simple things. And the idea of the influencer
has come from epidemiology. It's come from
the idea of like a super spreader, someone
who gets sick. They talk to a lot of people,
then a lot of people get sick.
Speaker 1: So interestingly, I mean, I like
the example of you talked about coconut water.
It sounds like part of this is coconut water
is not something that too many people that
I know at least feel very strongly about.
They may not feel very strongly one way or
the other. And that's very different than
something like, for example, vaccine hesitancy.
And so what might work with something relatively
innocuous, like coconut water would not necessarily
work with something like vaccination.
Speaker 2: Yeah, and the core scientific distinction
here is between what's called simple contagion
and complex contagion. And this is the big
breakthrough, right. To the science of contagion
20 years ago look very different than it does
today. We've had a lots of new methods, but
also lots of new theoretical breakthroughs.
And that's kind of what this book is about.
And what these insights are about is that
when we look at the spread of simple contagions,
which basically means information and disease,
it tends to be the case that all you need
is exposure to one infected or activated person
to transmit it. Right. Someone tells you a
new piece of information. You don't really
look around to say how many other people knew
this piece of information. You say, oh, lucky
me, I found this out first and then you can
repeat it. There's actually a certain cachet
to the novelty of the information. The same
is true with the covid-19 virus. If no one
you know is sick, it doesn't really matter.
All you need is contact with one sick person
to transmit the disease. Right. Right. So
if you have an influenza is highly connected,
that can spread to a lot of people. The point
you're making is that, look, there's lots
of behaviors that aren't like that, that just
because we come into contact with them doesn't
mean we adopt them. In fact, we look really
carefully at who that person is. Maybe that
person is different from us. We belong to
one political party. They belong to a different
one. We have we have one group of social friends.
They have very different friends. And as a
result of those differences and the sort of
social factors that we really perceive without
even thinking about it, we evaluate their
behavior, maybe reject it and say that's kind
of deviant or I disagree with that. The people
in my social group aren't doing that. And
so mere exposure isn't enough for transmission.
Speaker 1: Now, it actually seems like there's
some research, including from the field of
behavioral economics and also social psychology,
that certain types of beliefs, beliefs there
may be in certain buckets that might include
religious beliefs, political beliefs, et cetera,
sometimes regularly coming into contact with
with a different perspective will make you
kind of plant your feet where you are. If
you identify that those with a different view
are from an outgroup, that is not your group.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And that's it even gets worse.
It's not just playing in your feet. It's actually
you retreat back into your kind of doubled
down on your position. There's turn to turn
biased assimilation just means we assimilate
new information. It kind of a biased way where
the bias of our group helps us determine we
believe and we can actually become even more
entrenched in our beliefs as a result of confronting
conflicting ideas. But the punch line here
is this this discovery of complex contagion
that there's this whole class of things that
we deeply care about. Right. Everything from
disruptive products to new political initiatives
to initiatives for vaccination are difficult
to adopt. And they spread through networks
in a different way. And it means that all
of our classic theories, intuitions and strategies
from epidemiology and informational marketing
not only don't work, but they can backfire
in sort of the way you described. They can
backfire in the sense that they can make people
more entrenched in a position as opposed to
helping loosen their biases or weaken their
biases. But also there's lots of really sort
of famous cases. Of using influencers to advertise
a product and making a product less appealing
because of the way that the influencers were
so different from everybody else. Oh, what
Speaker 1: kind of what are some examples
of that?
Speaker 2: The most conspicuous one is the
is Google Plus and Google Glass. Right. A
lot of us remember Google Glass and Google
use the kind of influencer strategy they got
high profile wealthy techie people in the
San Francisco Bay Area, cutting edge people
who are on the sort of forefront of social
technical sophistication to start wearing
glass. And the idea was this was supposed
to create aspiration. We're all supposed to
want to be like the influencer, which is the
influencer model. Right. And they go out to
restaurants and coffee shops and they say,
I'm wearing their fancy eyewear so everyone
knows it's their right. So lots of exposure
will end up happening. Was this tremendous
cultural backlash. And everyone remembers
that the term was sort of invented by people
who encountered this, the term glassell, right,
for someone who would actually wear it. And
that was to distinguish people who were part
of that sort of influencer cutting edge from
the rest of us. And that was the sort of the
crux of their failure, is they didn't take
into account that most people have social
norms that would cause them to reject this
idea. Norms about surveillance and public
norms, about like just decorum in social interactions.
The idea that you'd be browsing the web while
talking to someone. Right. People were genuinely
offended by this technology. And so this is
an instance where just trying to kind of force
it on the population by going through the
influencers didn't take into account the fact
that the population is people with beliefs
and norms. And if they don't like it, they
don't like the way that this is being introduced.
It's actually going to be something that's
viewed in a very negative way as this, not
only because the product line to be stopped
entirely, but it actually hurt the reputation
of the company. So that's like that's a colossal
backfire. Yeah. And so it's a good example
of the sort of the issue when it comes to
change. And the issue is social norms. The
issue is you have to think about who the people
are and what their beliefs are and then how
those beliefs could change. And this is kind
of a famous thing in public health that public
health initiatives for decades have faced
this challenge from trying to spread HIV prevention
technologies to now trying to spread face
masks and then trying to spread vaccination.
And most of the initial cases were in sub-Saharan
Africa. And we had a lot of data about failures
of massive efforts by the CDC and the NIH
to change people's behavior about HIV prevention.
And there kind of hair pulling experiences
of realizing just how bad their messaging
strategy is based on influencers and based
on stickiness and based on viral messaging,
how badly it backfired, where no one would
actually wind up using a technology that was
free, easy to use and available like all the
things they're supposed to make us wanted.
Speaker 1: And yeah, I remember some examples
from the 2014 Ebola situation where Western
doctors were sent into the most ass at risk
and affected countries to to talk about how
this spreads. And it was just completely rejected
because they were the wrong messengers. It
didn't matter what they were going to say.
They were just not the right messengers for
that community.
Speaker 2: Right? It was it was ultimately
Ebola was viewed as a white disease because
you had so many white physicians in these
situations giving advice to to locals that
really contradicted local local religious
norms, like there is one in particular of
what's called standing near the ill, which
is exactly what it sounds like. You actually
physically locate yourself near a sick person
and it's kind of a spiritual commitment to
them. But of course, Ebola isn't seemingly
contagious. And so they wanted to do is to
separate people from people who had open wounds
and were highly infectious. And so the that
was viewed as a kind of cultural profanity
and and it sort of fell along race lines and
along cultural lines. And that, again, created
a kind of distance that physicians for this
authority figure telling people what to do
and populations resisted. And to bring it
back to the point of what complex contagion's
mean for us. Now, this is exactly what's happening
with vaccination, right? We're getting a lot
of medical experts, that kind of authority
figures, high profile people telling people
what to do. And you're getting populations
kind of galvanizing, experiencing solidarity
around their vaccination resistance. And so
the whole strategy in the book, which the
book was published before all this happened.
Right. But it actually is completely relevant
to these challenges because the whole strategy
in the book is about when influencers fail,
how to engage social networks in a way that
can shift social norms and make people more
receptive to new ideas. And so there's story
after story. I talk about Black Lives Matter.
I talk about the civil rights movement. I
talk about the Berlin Wall protests, all these
different sort of examples of how these social
change initiatives succeeded. Actually, they're
technology examples like Facebook and Twitter,
but the punch line is that the key to social
change is kind of the last place you would
think to look. It's actually out in the sort
of margins of the social network. It's sort
of the outer edges, the people who are regular
folks. And what we're looking for here isn't
special people, which has been the model for
a very long time. Influencers are somehow
different from the rest of us, and that makes
them the key change where we're actually looking
for are these special locations in the network,
these sort of patterns in the geometry of
our social connectedness. And when we find
those which are actually fairly easy to find,
we can actually identify locations where it's
fairly easy and practical to initiate a kind
of a critical mass dynamic where we kind of
grow support for a new movement that might
challenge what people believe. But because
there's reinforcement among friends of friends
and because it's sort of in locally clustered
group, they can sort of shift away from whatever
the status quo is. And then once that critical
mass takes hold, basically, then you get a
cascade process where kind of flows through
the rest of the network. And once a critical
mass becomes large enough, this is where we
see tipping points happen. Right. And this
is kind of what we saw as Black Lives Matter.
Black Lives Matter was this marginal fringe
movement that took hold just regular people
in communities. And then once it got large
enough, you saw white suburban housewives
marching with black inner city youth for Black
Lives Matter, which is something that no one
could have anticipated, you know, five years
earlier. And so it's a real change in like
who's part of this process. And all of a sudden
everyone was part of this process. And that's
when we see a tipping point. That's exactly
what we see. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Anecdotally, we've we've seen that
even just like with the growth of you take
any one of our platforms like YouTube, where
there seems to be this geometric curve that
happens, where initially the amount of work
required for a little bit of growth is huge,
like our first thousand subscribers, our first
ten thousand subscribers, you then get enough
critical mass where maybe you get a tipping
point where you quickly get to, you know,
one hundred or two hundred thousand. And then
there's a period where it slows down again
and then you get sort of to the next tipping
point. Is that typical of the types of movements
you study as well?
Speaker 2: Yeah, it's typical of almost every
large scale growth curve. This was in the
back in the 60s, 1969, 1970. There's this
famous thing was called the Basker. And this
was he was just describing like consumer electronics,
durable goods like refrigerators or like televisions
and like what those growth curves look like.
But what wasn't explained was the social mechanics
that allowed that growth curve to happen.
And most importantly, that that elbow in the
curve where you go from slow global growth
into that kind of like rapidly accelerating,
like exponential growth, you know, week after
week what's happening at that elbow. And that
was just unexplained. It was like, well, it
took off, but like, OK, so what is that? And
there are a lot of things that start to grow
slowly and then peter out. So what's the difference
between those two things? And that's where
my book sort of answers that question says,
well, plenty of things start to grow, but
they never get into the networks in the right
way. And so they kind of peter out. But if
you get into networks in the right way, when
you start to grow, you actually build. Oh,
that was one of my legs. You actually build
an earphone that you guys said, you build
your phone, you can take that up. You actually
you actually build a a kind of contagion process
built within the infrastructure of the social
network. Right. That then basically forms
the basis of the critical mass. And that is
the difference between the cases where you
get that elbow up and the pace in the cases
where you just kind of peter out. And that's
kind of the powerful lesson, is that that's
something we can control. We can do experiments
on it. More importantly, we can develop policy
around.
Speaker 1: That makes a ton of sense. And
we've been we've been speaking about much
of what is in Dayman Sentell is book change
how to make big things happen. He is a professor
in a number of disciplines at the University
of Pennsylvania. Damons, so great speaking
to you today. Absolutely. Thank you.